cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
oh boy this is a good one New Mexico
attorney general says he won't defend
governor in lawsuits over ban on
carrying guns my duty to uphold and
defend the Constitution writes
constitutional rights of every citizen
takes precedence so let me just let me
break this down for you guys what this
means all right many of you probably
know but the AG is the state's top
lawyer when they're sued it's the
attorney general who is going to be
dealing with drafting a lawsuit or a
rebuttal or whatever and filing lawsuit
on behalf of the state and uh this means
the governor will be on her own and I I
don't I don't know how she's gonna pull
this off there are already lawsuits
being filed for the decree to ban guns
the AG is like I'm not defending you
you're on your own so how is her office
going to do to respond to this it's
going to be default judgment instantly
across the board that's amazing I mean
so that she might actually lose her
office I mean the taxpayer could lose a
lot of money from this yeah well and and
I'm I you know I'm hoping and I mean I
could talk about it personally but I'll
just make a general statement I'd like
to see any attorney general I wouldn't
expect that from Merrick Garland anytime
soon but I'd like to see a widespread
approach from any sort of attorneys
generals that says we are not going to
prosecute speech yeah you bring us you
bring a free speech case to us we are
not going to prosecute it we are going
to toss it out much like what you're
seeing with this New Mexico case
I think I don't know I've got a theory
about this New Mexico case I think it
was a trial balloon yep I think you know
they they just they knew what they were
doing they did it in New Mexico for a
reason they didn't do it in the
northeast or anything like that and they
ran this up the flagpole to see what the
response would be they enlisted this
Governor to do it
they got blow back they must have seen
some internal polls in the first 24
hours that were off the wall bad and
that's why they they sent out David Hogg
and uh who was the other big uh Pro guy
oh yeah all of their tweets were the
exact same language there is no State
exemption to the cut to a constitutional
success right but I'd like to introduce
them to their opinions during covid
because exactly yeah quite the opposite
this is what they do though they
manufacture a crisis they make up a
crisis out of thin air and then they go
down this path and the next thing you
know you have no rights yeah right so
this I think was a trial balloon it was
trying to pave the path to kind of
normalize this kind of thing so while
we're celebrating that it didn't work
now they're they're they're taking
another step to normalizing taking away
your guns and what's even more
frustrating again it gets back to the
same issue there is no data that
supports this approach there is no data
that supports this policy and in fact
and in fact the exact opposite whether
it's Kennesaw Georgia where it's the
most heavily armed County and there's
the least amount of gun crime or whether
it's what happened in Brazil recently or
they always point to Australia and they
say oh we got rid of the guns and the
guns crime went down actually when they
made the new laws in Australia more gun
purchases happened there I'm sorry oh
and you're wrong uh you're just wrong
there's tons of data showing that what
they're doing Works in a Communist
Revolution
exactly so uh but but wait are we in the
Communist Revolution is
but let's be serious yes
their view on why you shouldn't have
guns is not based on your view of why
you should have guns when we say things
like hey look I live in a semi-rural
area mostly rural area and the police
aren't going to be here if we if we've
got a serious issue so we need to defend
ourselves you know when they do want to
defund the police too so that's not an
out of left field argument that's very
relevant the the argument that we have
is if you have aegon you are safer the
argument they have is I will lie to you
because in order to steal political
power I have to take away your ability
to fight back or defend yourself and
then you and and also the creation of
anarcho tyranny you look at what's
happening in San Francisco you see that
viral video of the young woman being
like I parked at a time what did you
like parked at a Taco Bell or something
and then went inside for five minutes
which one oh I know there's dozens of
these now tourists that's embarrassing
as an American remember when CNN twice
that happened to CNN and we laugh about
it like ah you put you so but it's the
intent no it's actually it's the
anarchitarian they want there was a
story
um out of St Louis where a young
volleyball player high school volleyball
star was set to go on scholarship play
volleyball in high school uh College
rather she's at a high school volleyball
tournament in St Louis she leaves the
tournament she's walking outside she
gets run over and paralyzed and can no
longer play volleyball the individual
that ran her over was on release already
a multiple time offender on release Let
Go by a George Soros liberal attorney
and what do you know caused harm again
but but you know I I would go because
here's here's where I think the legal
Theory needs to go and this would
probably nip this ride in the bud
let's let's propose a hypothetical here
let's say that the New Mexico governor
somehow is able to disarm the citizenry
okay and let's say let's say let's say
Monica you live in New Mexico and you're
like oh my gosh the governor's right I'm
turning over my firearms okay you've now
turned over your Firearms you're a great
person the policy's working well what
happens and I'm sorry I'm not trying to
traumatize you what happens when a
criminal with a gun breaks into your
house rapes you and murders you is the
governor now complicit in that crime
how is she not and libel how is she not
you you were disarmed some legal
responsibility then for disarming me
that's what I'm saying if I come up and
I disarm you and then and then seconds
later
somebody comes up and commits a crime to
you well I helped cause that crime to be
committed I made you a victim took a
defensive way
but is anybody thinking about that legal
Theory because to me that's that's the
the one thing again and this goes back
whether it's the illegal immigration the
Democrats hating the taste of their own
medicine that's the one thing that will
always stand down a communist when they
realize they're going to be held
responsible when bad things happen when
they realize they're going to be held
responsible that will stop them they
just think they're above it all yeah
they do well they're also protected from
the consequences of their own policies
and decisions right because they live in
the gated communities they've got that
armed security and the rest look
throughout history anytime the
Communists have come to power one of the
very first things they do is empty all
the prisons yeah so all the violent
criminals pour out onto the streets why
because Communists need the violent
Mayhem they need the violent chaos to
destabilize Society to slam into place
what they want yeah it's like they're
the ones with the with the control and
all the actual system yeah it's like
Ghostbusters when uh exactly it is like
what was the guy's name Peck or whatever
I don't remember he turns off the
containment field and releases in New
York City
chaos yeah yeah you know we can't have
that yeah I mean I think that joke for
me like 800 times about how they're
releasing everybody from prisons that's
true yeah well I mean it it doesn't have
to be releasing they could just not put
people in prison with that or criminals
but look I I gotta say I gotta say you
know a few people have responded when I
keep saying that we're winning and
they're saying no we've only just
stopped losing and I'm like you've got
to have morale you know like if if all
of if you're in a battle you know if
it's an actual War and the enemy
controls 80 of the battlefield and
you're making small gains you don't go
we're really losing this one guys but I
guess we'll keep going you say we're
taking it we're winning storm head and
you don't know what I see
sure the left controls the institutions
look what they're trying to do with
banning guns they're losing these moves
aren't working it doesn't mean they're
not trying and you give up it means
we're watching them break ranks when
they break ranks you don't run away you
don't say oh gee will like gee well
we're losing here you say charge so when
I see the tremendous economic success of
all of these parallel economic Brands
when I see I mean they tried to destroy
my pillow my pillow's still around you
can't get rid of those pillows don't you
say it's a lumpy pillow
that's a lumpy pillow I saw that video I
was just gonna reference that when uh
it's it's
um Mike Lindell in a deposition I think
it was right yep and then they they he
mentioned the guy says something about
your lumpy pillows he's like how dare
you it is not a lumpy pillow it was
really good I mean my pillows are
awesome by the way but anyway you look
at that you look at
um even right now uh you've got cousin
T's pancake mix there you go you got
Jeremy's razors Jeremy's chocolate
conservative dad's Ultra ripe beer and
now their limited editions conservatives
dad's Revenge yeah we're having fun
we're having fun and laughing as we
build Alternatives and get rich doing it
and we keep the the money within our
system look at rumble's success their
new UI let me tell you this the success
of Rumble I was on Instagram looking at
skateboard videos and I saw a video I
think it was Paul Rodriguez one of the
most famous skateboarders in the world
at his private park and Rumble Sports
was on their wall and I'm like when
regular old skateboarders are going to
rumble to watch skateboarding YouTube's
in trouble and we're winning the culture
War because Rumble the politics of
Rumble are all the refugees of YouTube
who got censored in band which are more
and more more and more but if kids
younger teenagers are going to go to
rumble and they're watching
skateboarding what's on their
recommendation list for podcasts it's
going to be Real News Real information
it's going to be independent media and
the Machine can't control that anymore
well and I think too when you talk about
the emergence of Rumble as I mean I
would say it's the number one competitor
to YouTube on on a large scale hands
down they're really still kind of in the
primordial ooze of of what they could
potentially be and as I know as a
Creator yourself you know that there's a
lot of bells and whistles that they're
going to be needing to Tinker with and
fix but they're still kind of they're
still kind of crawling out of that that
media ooze to to become a much better
platform but you know when you get to
them when you get to the issue that you
bring up where people say oh we're not
winning or oh this is bad morale down I
think there's I think there's I mean I
could boil it down to two fundamental
questions that I would respond to
somebody like that and I would just say
and and you know maybe people will
answer how they want and I would just
say Do you believe America is worth
fighting for yeah do you believe freedom
is worth fighting for I I've been saying
to people uh when they say like you know
how do I get started I want to make
videos or I'll do a podcast I'm like
just do it on Rumble because YouTube's
not safe YouTube's got too many barriers
it's too hard to to exist on and it's
not worth it especially I'll tell you
this right now
this is actually really really funny the
amount of money we make on YouTube has
gone down you know why because so many
of our viewers have moved to rumble we
now average for Tim cast IRL I think
around 50 000 views on Rumble per clip
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time